well being the first Monday in September
that means it's the start of the new
school year for many students around the
world now here in Russia Foreign
Minister Sergey Lavrov being
congratulating students at his alma
mater the Moscow State Institute of
International Relations the potential
future diplomats in the audience got
some insight into Russia's foreign
policy there is a group of countries led
by the u.s. that don't want dialogue and
instead of diplomacy want to use
dictates ultimatums and blackmail he's
swatting up on that session for us
correspondent Daniel Hawkins hi there a
new school year but the same old
problems for Russia it seems what else
did mr. Lavrov have to say to the
students yeah it did seem that way
congratulations two new students from
mr. Lavrov an update on international
affairs and criticism for us-led foreign
policy that was all present in his
speech and subsequent Q & A session he
was very careful to reiterate the
importance of dialogue negotiation and
compromise on differing interests in
international relations Syria was one of
the examples he mentioned with an update
on the province of Idlib where he said
ceasefire negotiations are still taking
place that Russia was being very careful
to separate terrorists from moderate
armed opposition and create humanitarian
corridors for anyone wishing to leave
the area he did however reiterate
Damascus does have the right to clear
the area of armed radicals who continue
he said to attack Syrian army positions
and the Russian air base as well a lot
of time dedicated in his Q&A session to
US UK Russia relations as well he said
that as we heard in that grab Russia
doesn't recognize the illegitimate
actions of the United States and
pressure threats coercion sanctions etc
and he described a sad state of affairs
where a russophobic Lobby with in
Washington is preventing an improvement
in relations through talks by the two
leaders he also commented on the scruple
case in subsequent sections stating that
the u.s. is quote doing the UK's dirty
work for it by imposing these sanctions
and which he said will not be left
unaddressed let's take a listen
we've afternoon Shiraz canisters we
won't leave this unaddressed it won't
necessarily be a symmetrical response I
don't think a symmetrical response is
always the best method sanctions were
imposed in terms of absolutely false
statements
despite that he said Russia won't fall
into hysterics as he sat and is still
open to dialogue he said nothing is
irreversible
and nothing is totally broken in UK
Russia relations and this these
relations this relationship had been
quote artificially damaged by the
scruple case he said the ball is very
much in London's Court in Washington's
court for this improvement finally he
said that Russia's aim ultimately is
peace and stability around its own
borders and the resolution as we said
earlier of crises through deployed
diplomacy and negotiation with their
partners despite the very obvious
present difficulties they face I wonder
if any of the undergrads had any
suggestions for the foreign minister all
right for now though done Hawkins thanks
for that
you